I did have acquaintances with famous
scientists very early in my career this
is actually looking back at this it is
actually strange how early I was put
together on important occasions with
many Nobel laureates the most important
connection for me he was with Max Perutz
and this happened in the way that I
started to work on hemoglobin in
connection with my sports interest in
improving oxygen supply so I actually
took my own blood and studied my own
hemoglobin and when Max Perutz heard I
was at Bell Telephone labs at the time
this was in 1968 and when Max Perutz
heard about this work he bought the
plane ticket and came to the United
States to see me and so he contacted the
head of research at Bell Labs who didn't
know me of course cuz I was a very
junior member of technical staff and
then eventually I found out what he
wanted and and he spent two days with me
just untenable slides from me which he
showed around the world because what I
did was my email open was fully
complementary to his Nobel Prize work on
hemoglobin and we had interactions
continuously he his mother-in-law left
in theory so he had to visit Sri several
times a year and he would come to the
lab he would he would give seminars one
hour with two hours seminars to my group
which was about five students at the
time just come to my office and talk to
this you
for the now he was very enthusiastic
about this work so that was the closest
connection but then I learned to know
John Kendrew fitzy linen then we had
long tours in the Soviet Union on
invitation by of chinoco there would be
polling Dorothy Hodgkin and so on that's
why I main God with these people were
all thirty years older than me and I
lost fear of these people you see if you
spend two weeks with polling you know
about his weaknesses a belt as well as
about this intellectual strength and
that's very reassuring in some ways